I think that was a place that Pascal
sakam approved to get bet traded to
Pascal sakam is a Toronto Raptor Legend
he's going to be respected there was
some communication there he's not going
to send Pascal somewhere that Pascal
doesn't want to be just to get the
biggest bang for the buck back for the
Raptors not how Messi movement I know
that's somewhere that Pascal had to say
oh I'd be cool going there and why
wouldn't he be you got a very young just
signed a Max contract point guard are
soon to be Allstar Tyrese halberton
that's a dream for a guy like cakle also
got a big man rim protector and Miles
Turner and Pascal cakam has come through
the East to win a championship so he's
very familiar with the Eastern
Conference I can roll with that now I
come in I bring my Championship pedigree
my veteran presence with those young
them them boys running now I can bring
my veteran presence to that my
Championship pedigree I like the look of
that